hello ladies and gentlemen apparently I
am on air now and this is my first time
ever doing a google hangout like this so
yeah this is exciting I so by the way
I'm totally ignorant about how this
works so I should be able to see you
guys commenting and stuff but I can't
and I'm not totally sure how to go about
doing that so bear with me as I look
stuff up here hold on
I'm gonna
see events
so I see that there's some cool people
in the comment section if I actually go
on to the the live page if anyone can
tell me in the comments here how do I
look at comments while I am in the
on-air by the way this library I'm
house-sitting right now I'm watching
this little dog right here I don't know
if you can see here come here come on
and this is not my library I wish it was
alright yeah okay so I'm getting told
that I am having an echo
you can watch the comment stream on the
playback okay well I guess I have to
keep an eye on both things here what I'm
gonna do because I can't look at
comments while I'm actually just using
the on-air app I should have kept this a
secret I should have told everyone this
is my library yeah because I can't look
at comments while I'm doing the the
while I'm in the broadcasting app I will
go back and forth so kind of between
major parts of the presentation we'll
come back here and look at comments and
try and respond to comments and that'll
go back to my presentation so I've got a
couple of things I'm going to be doing
here originally I wanted to talk about
to answer three different questions one
is on butterflies had a butterflies
evolve particularly had a metamorphosis
evolve one is on how did how did the
counter-current heat exchange system in
whale testicles evil
and then am I still getting my reverb
people
so what I did is I turn the sound down
on my computer Sam hope hopefully that
ended the reverb okay cool people are
saying that I'm good now
all right great and then the third
question I was going to answer here
today is how does evolution take
something from no function to function
how does function evolve from non
function and that third question as I
was preparing slides last night I
realized that is a huge topic in and of
itself and I think I should probably do
an entire video just about that so I'm
gonna do I'm gonna save that for next
Sunday so today I'm going to I'm gonna
share with you some slides of mine so
let me share my screen here share screen
and we'll we'll jump into this okay
Google Hangouts is sharing your screen
okay so again bear with me folks I'm
totally new to this hopefully hopefully
this will be a thing that I do regularly
hopefully this Sunday morning science
thing will be you know something that I
do every week we'll see how this this
first attempt goes so metamorphosis that
this is the question that I got in
metamorphosis what were the stages by
which it evolved and hopefully I'm
pronouncing this name right
Rodie green asked that rowdy rody Rudy
so butterflies are absolutely amazing
these are two owl butterflies that I got
to hang out with when I was in Ecuador a
few months back
Nancy Morelli took me on a tour that an
insect who were in one of our stops was
this butterfly farm these butterflies
are absolutely amazing they got this
these uh these I spot
on them that look just like eyes
including the little highlight spots
which i think is great and this is
supposedly a defense against predators
having these creepy looking eyes on
their wings creeps out you know
potential predators but metamorphosis is
an absolutely spectacular thing I mean
when I first started learning about
evolution first started thinking about
evolution
metamorphosis was one of the one of the
issues that I had with evolution how on
earth could something this spectacular
have evolved because when I was probably
in second grade maybe was third grade
our teacher brought in some caterpillars
we had this little terrarium setup with
caterpillars in it and then there were
monarch butterflies they were eating
milkweed and we watched them form
chrysalis and we watched them come out
of that chrysalis and turn into
butterflies
absolutely spectacular if you've never
done this I highly recommend you know
you can buy them online and you can you
can watch this happen on your own it's a
really really fascinating process and
the they're just amazing amazing animals
these caterpillars are nothing like the
adults they eat completely different
food the adults eat eat nectar mainly
and the larvae the caterpillars they eat
plant material they just they munch on
leaves very fascinating process this the
these animals do this it's almost like
they're two completely separate animals
from from larvae to adult and here we
have a chrysalis a lot of people think
that butterflies spin a cocoon at the
chrysalis is a cocoon it's not you see
up top here there's a little bit of silk
that's holding the chrysalis to the in
this case is a piece of wood here the
the chrysalis is actually just the
animal skin when you have a you have a
caterpillar like this and attaches
itself to a stick when it's mature and
then I'd actually sheds its skin
chrysalis is and a layer underneath the
caterpillar it it forms an Eleni and the
caterpillar skin is shed and then the
chrysalis is shed again and out comes
the butterfly so that's how that's how
the process works it's a it's a type of
molting you know molting is very common
in insects of all kinds and to
metamorphosis has these you know well a
butterfly goes through four life stages
it starts out as an egg hatches as
larvae out of that egg and the larva
grows and changes quite a bit throughout
its its life throughout the caterpillars
life then it goes into a pupa stage
chrysalis and then it comes out of that
as an adult and one of the reasons that
I struggled to understand how this could
have evolved when I first started
thinking about evolution and remembering
back to my days in elementary school
when when we'd seen this happen is I
thought when I first started you know
this was in high school I suppose maybe
middle school when I first started
learning about evolution thinking about
evolution at the time I thought that
butterflies and moths were the only
things that went through metamorphosis
and you know it's like this unique thing
for butterflies and moths and how on
earth would something like that evolve
that didn't make any sense to me right
but our butterflies and moths really
alone and this thing that we call
metamorphosis no they are not alone
beetles go through metamorphosis here on
the left here we see a beetle larva this
this worm light guy and then we see a
beetle pupae so it's like a beetle
chrysalis you could say on the right and
then behind this guy's hand he's holding
what the actual there's there's a what
the actual adult beetles look like this
is a Hercules beetle giant giant beetle
and then on the right here I've got baby
bees bees start out as little larva
little maggot like critters well they
started out as a
which those are eggs that you see on the
right then you see the larva on the left
here and absolutely fascinating and then
of course flies start out as maggots
right so metamorphosis is extremely
common and it turns out that there are
most species of animals on earth are
beetles you know and so it turns out
that it's well not most a huge
percentage of the species on earth are
beetles there are 350 thousand species
of beetle that have been recognized and
named there's only 250 thousand species
of plants and there's only four thousand
species of mammals and so when you think
about all the different types of animals
that go through metamorphosis you know a
huge percentage of animals species on
planet Earth are species that go through
metamorphosis
so butterflies and moths are definitely
not alone in this metamorphosis is an
extremely common process in the animal
kingdom and hold on let me go back here
one of the big benefits of metamorphosis
is that metamorphosis
it allows the parent and the child to
not compete with each other for food
resources
that's when evolutionary biologists look
at this and try and figure out what the
heck what the heck is metamorphosis
really doing for these animals what it's
doing is its allowing the parents an
offspring not to compete with each other
for food because the parents eat nectar
and the offspring they are you know the
larvae they eat plant material this is
not the case with humans you know humans
the parents and the children eat pretty
much the same thing and so we really are
in competition with each other for
resources we've evolved this these
strong parental instincts that stop us
from competing with each other but we
are in competition with each other for
resources even when a baby is still
drinking milk it's taking that milk
directly from the mothers
there is this competition between a
parent and child which does not exist in
animals that go through metamorphosis so
that's that is the most obvious benefit
of metamorphosis and that's why
metamorphosis is so common among animals
animal species you could also say that
frogs undergo metamorphosis and for a
similar reason the tadpoles and the
adult frogs eat different food sources
so forward here there's a over the
comments back in the back in the 60s
there's a biologist and I'm blanking on
his name right now I had notes that I
had written but I don't know what I did
with those they're somewhere in the
other room but he was asked you know
what is it that biology can tell us
about God and he said well when you look
at biology you realize that if God is
real and he did create life on Earth he
has an inordinate an inordinate love for
beetles because there's so many of them
compared to all the other species I
thought that was kind of funny we can
think of a caterpillar as a fetus that
was born early and went out started
getting its own food and then kind of
went dormant again to mature into an
adult form so we actually go through
dramatically different body stages as
well just like a caterpillar does to a
butterfly but most of those dramatic
changes happen while we're still safely
inside the womb you know we start out
this is a human fetus I forget the age
that this fetus is at this is it this is
a human it's got a little tail there
it's got two it's got little little leg
buds down at the bottom that kind of
that bolds down there and those are leg
buds and on the side here our arm buds
just kind of get started there
and one of the really fascinating things
about a chrysalis you know when when a
caterpillar goes into this chrysalis
stage if you were to cut open a
chrysalis all sorts of goo would leak
out because what happens while when the
when the animal is in chrysalis form is
a bunch of its cells dissolve and and
they new cells start forming start
growing and start developing the adult
body parts and this this cell death is
called apoptosis and it's a process that
our bodies go through to quite
dramatically when we're fetuses so you
can see these little arm buds coming out
here we actually grow flippers as hands
and then we go through apoptosis between
the fingers in our hands to to to slice
up that flipper into the five fingers
that we end up having as as we mature
and so this process of development and
then cell death is super common in our
own bodies this is common all across
biology and it seems really magical
really special and metamorphosis in
butterflies because so much of it
happens all at once but this process is
normal this is a normal thing that
happens in all organisms and so it's
it's not when you start to learn this
you start to realize that metamorphosis
is not as strange as it seems at first
all organisms go through this really the
big difference is that the caterpillar
goes through you know it it hatches and
it lives its life in its fetal stage for
a while and then it goes dormant and
then matures into an adult and then
lives its life as an adult that's that's
the main difference between butterflies
and humans for example now not all
insects go through metamorphosis but all
insects do go through a you know a
gradual process of going from
to adult this here these are milkweed
bugs and you can see here on the right
we've got little babies they got little
stubby wings that don't work that are
kind of underneath their their
exoskeletons there and then on the left
here we've got the adult with full nice
mature wings and with these insects
here's here's more examples of them they
go through multiple stages they go
through multiple molt's throughout their
life in each time they molt they change
a little bit and when when we when we
compare this type of lifecycle
it's pretty much exactly the same as
metamorphosis except for the changes
that happen the these little spurts of
cell death and growth they happen
incrementally they happen a little bit
at a time whereas in a butterfly or a
beetle they go into a dormant stage that
the chrysalis and then they go through
massive amounts of change all at once so
you can really think of this as
metamorphosis as a condensed normal
growth of an insect
it just all that happens at once we kind
of do this as well we have a puberty
stage and during puberty actually
there's there's actually a lot of cell
death during puberty our sex organs go
through a lot of cell death during
puberty and growth at the same time
there's so we actually kind of go
through a type of metamorphosis though
it's much more mild than butterflies do
so again this is very very familiar to
us when we when we dig in and start
looking at all the examples that exist
in nature this is a silverfish and
silverfish go through no metamorphosis
at all so these these milkweed bugs go
through what what some people call
partial metamorphosis it's actually good
it's called Hemi metabolize
metamorphosis that error that's there
that's there
growth style that's the technical word
for it and metamorphosis auto metabolize
but silkworms very sorry silverfish
don't go through any sort of
metamorphosis at all they just they just
go through growth stages where it pretty
much the the babies when they hatch they
already look like miniature adults and
they just get bigger when they molt and
they they just kind of grow up as a baby
as you would expect a really simple form
of maturation to it to work they do
inside the egg they they kind of go
through these same fetal stages they
they go through a larval like stage but
that happens all inside the egg just
like for us it happens inside the womb
caterpillars are just exceptions where
they come out early so metamorphosis
what are the stages by which it evolved
this is pretty much it there are these
three stages that we can see in living
organisms today and it in insects today
we can see that there are insects that
go through no metamorphosis
metamorphosis at all there are insects
that go through partial metamorphosis
and there are insects that go through
full-blown metamorphosis and we can
think of this full-blown metamorphosis
as just partial metamorphosis where all
that change is condensed into just one
dormant period that the chrysalis stage
or the I'm liking the other term for
that it's a pupa stage a lot of times
when a you know when beetles and stuff
go through it we call it a pupa stage
and that's I think really just because
people didn't realize that it's the same
thing when they were naming it in the
first place so that's that's my response
for that question I'm gonna go to I'm
gonna pull out of here I'm gonna stop
sharing my screen for a moment and I'm
gonna go back to let's see now there's
me again
again I'm totally new to this live
broadcast stuff so bear with me here I'm
gonna get back to see comments looking
at comments
don't you ever address questions
so I'm now looking in the chat here for
a moment I'm gonna try to address some
people's questions here let me see if we
got any what happens to the brain of the
thing when it morphs so we used to think
that when a butterfly goes or when a
butterfly is in a chrysalis that its
entire body dissolves and then grows and
new people thought that it was kind of
like a second egg that is not the case I
mean if you cut one open it kinda just
turns into goo and if you open it up it
it all pulls apart really easily and it
seems like the whole thing's dissolved
that's not actually not the case so
there are structures to stay intact the
nervous system parts of the nervous
system stay intact during all that
that's one of the really important
things to note and actually you can
adults butterflies will actually
remember things that they learned when
they were caterpillars which is
fascinating there's been experiments on
that a lot of the body actually does
stay intact so parts of it dissolve
parts of it stay intact you know the the
front three legs and a caterpillar end
up becoming the the the sorry the front
six legs in a caterpillar end up
becoming these six legs of the adult
there's a little bit of tissue in there
that that becomes the a kind of the the
butterfly body parts and I actually
there's a word for this so we call it
the imaginal discs they are these
cellular structures that never dissolve
during the poo
stage there are these little cellular
structures that start proliferating
rapidly after the the chrysalis is
formed and those end up giving rise to
the adult stages and so those exist in
the base of the legs and they exist and
a bunch of different stages a bunch of
different spots in the body of the
caterpillar so they're already in there
and actually in some some moths for
example like silk the the models we used
for silks those silkworms you can
actually dissect a silkworm and find a
miniature wings underneath its skin
they're really primitively formed wings
but they're there and those just start
to grow rapidly once they go into a
chrysalis form and actually spin a
cocoon and go into a chrysalis
so everything is already there it's
hopefully that answers that question
let's see and there's a lot of people
talking in here and it's kind of hard to
see actual questions
[Music]
if any of you have some questions and I
didn't answer instead of me scrolling
back through all of the the discussion
here asked them again before I go
through before I go to the next little
presentation here I'd like to try and
answer any questions that you have on
this okay
so it's asked if you mixed butterfly
soup within the chrysalis with some
other butterfly soup would I just kill
them or could you get a new butterfly
maybe that's actually an interesting
question I don't I don't know that
anyone's done that I would imagine that
it would it would be fatal to the animal
but you might be able to get away with
that I the reason I say would probably
be fatal is you know our bodies our
immune systems at least in mammals
attack foreign cells and I imagine that
the same is true and insects but I don't
know that's a good that's a really good
question
you certainly could move things around
in there if you're really careful and
get things to come out messed up that's
likely possible but I don't think you
could actually mix parts from other
species can you Raikes well
why the creatures that metamorph you
said everything kind of does this so for
butterfly is that more advantage to meta
faster I don't really understand that
question
someone asked how did they
all those fake allies is that specific
to its location we don't really know
I guess step by step how that evolved
but we do know the genetics behind how
that works and I'm not familiar with it
enough to really talk about it with
authority here but there is a book I'm
blanking on the name of it right now
that I read years ago that talks about
the genetics of that and it's on
evolutionary development evo-devo
what's the name of that book it's if
anyone can think of that book put that
in the comments here it's by Sean
Carroll and it's kind of an over
overview of the science of evo-devo
evolutionary development which mixes
embryology with our understanding of
evolution - to give us you know to come
up with a better understanding of how
these different different things evolved
[Music]
also someone's asking I guess so why did
butterflies metamorph
in the first place you mentioned that
everything does this to some degree so
it's just better for butterflies to do
it all at once I think so what we think
happened there's there's a model of the
Selective pressures that might have
driven this type of evolution and we
think that this started out with babies
hatching prematurely so the cool thing
about being able to hatch prematurely is
that you don't need as as large of an
egg you know if you can if you can hatch
prematurely and then just eat a bunch of
food you don't need a huge egg with lots
of yolk to support you while you mature
so we
that probably the first step in the
evolution of metamorphosis was eggs
hatching early and you know so so they
hatch in these these larva States
because if you look at a silverfish for
example they they go through these same
stages this larva like stage but they do
that inside the egg so the first kind of
step in the evolution of metamorphosis
was hatching early and finding food on
their own and the huge advantage of that
is that you can lay more eggs because
the eggs are all smaller and so you know
that's that's an advantage in certain
environments being able to lay more eggs
that are smaller that would be an
advantage in any sort of an environment
where most of your kids are not going to
survive that type of adaptation would be
helpful having more kids and them having
to fend for themselves a little bit more
that could be an advantage and when we
when we look at the organisms that go
through partial metamorphosis like the
the milkweed bugs that I showed you and
by the way also grasshoppers go through
partial metamorphosis praying mantises
there's a whole bunch of animals of they
go through partial metamorphosis they
actually start out with some some of
them actually do hatch a little bit
early and they're in a kind of larval
egg stage but they they mature out of
that through Oh someone just said that
the name of the book it's at endless
forms most beautiful that's that's the
book where it goes into the detail of
the genetics and the the process behind
these eye spots and butterflies and I
apologize for not being fresh enough on
that to actually explain it here but
yeah that's that's the book endless
forms most beautiful
sorry I got sidetracked with my doing
these live chats I'm getting easily
sidetracked I apologize but the I was
talking about oh yeah why did why did
why was it an advantage to evolve
metamorphosis so the first big advantage
is being able to hatch early which
allows you to have smaller eggs because
you want to make all that yolk for your
egg too for it for your your baby to
mature fully before it hatches and the
second big advantage is you know not
being not having to compete with the
adults for food so these these animals
that go through partial metamorphosis as
they grow and as they mature they start
to compete more and more with their
parents for food and that's that's the
disadvantage of partial metamorphosis
and the big advantages of full
metamorphosis is is that you you don't
have to compete with your parents for
for food and so that's that's the model
that scientists have put forward right
now there's a really good article they
summarizes all the different thoughts
that scientists have had on why
metamorphosis evolved on scientific
America and if you if you do a google
for the evolution of metamorphosis
you'll find this pretty high up in the
Google search results it's it's an
article by scientific America well
actually let me try and pull that up
it's a really really good article and oh
how did insect metamorphosis evolve and
let me share my screen here hold on
shares great share who we got a tunnel
of infinity going on here oops
so here is the article
how did insect metamorphosis evolved and
I highly recommend reading through this
because it goes through a bunch of
different ideas that scientists have had
over the years it goes through the
history of the study of this you know it
in it talks about how in the early days
we used to think that the entire animal
melts inside of the chrysalis that does
not happen but it it goes through the
history of this and it's really really
fascinating and it highlights a the the
best model that we have which is put
forth by Lynn Ritter furred and James
Truman from the University of Washington
in Seattle and they actually go through
the genetics they actually show you from
a genes perspective even what's going on
and in the evolution of metamorphosis
and there's some really really neat
connections when you look at the
genetics between animals that go through
partial metamorphosis and animals go
through full metamorphosis and there's
some really neat connections between
even you know the way that humans mature
and the way that insects mature and and
go through these processes so check that
out and if you really want to get nerdy
go and read the actual scientific
literature there's links to that in this
article it's a really great article that
overviews everything so with that let me
let me get back to my presentation here
let's see
good Shannon Shannon mass but whale
balls don't worry that's the next topic
the next thing that we're going to talk
about here is well well I'm still
sharing my screen look at that whale
balls is next up on the list
okay let's pull up my presentation I
gotta go through the whole thing again
whale balls so I got this question on
this was probably years ago I I did an
animation for stated clearly for those
of you who don't know I am the guy that
does the stated clearly animations
that's my other youtube channel and
years ago I did an animation about the
evolution of whales and I got this
letter shortly after publishing that and
it was a very angry letter but I you
know when people are angry at me I like
to instead of responding in kind and
being angry back I like to try and see
if there's a legitimate question within
their angry comment and I like to just
try and respond to that question because
that's I mean that that's how we take
these horrible conversations that happen
online and turn them into productive
conversations right so he writes you
honestly think that whales evolved from
land animals learn biology and stop
lying to kids three exclamation points
you know all all-caps whales have
internal testicles cooled by a complex
counter-current cooling system you idiot
look it up how did that evolve here's a
link for you because you're clearly too
dumb to find it on your own and he sends
me a link to evolution news actually
sorry I said that this was this was a
while ago but this this email was
actually recent because this article is
recent so I've gotten a lot of emails
like this in the past but
he sends me a link to evolution
evolution news org and evolution news is
a website that's is was created by the
intelligent design community so the the
like you know Michael Behe and those
guys the Discovery Institute it's it's
this organization that's based in
Seattle and they they train they try and
put forth anti-evolution propaganda and
they built a website called evolution
news where they put forth all these
different lies about evolution all this
anti-evolution propaganda so he he sends
me a link to link there and and then he
quotes me a part of that that article it
says internalization of tests of the
testicle could not have proceeded the
counter current heat exchange system or
the mail cetacean cetaceans the
technical word for whale or the mail
citation would have been sterile yet
there is no adaptive advantage to having
a counter current heat exchange system
around the testicle unless it is inside
the body so here is the actual article
that came from and it's written by
Jonathan wells
Jonathan wells is a biologist he's a PhD
biologist that um you know he got his
PhD so that he could write creationist
material and have some credentials
behind him his stuff is absolute garbage
he wrote a book I have his I have one of
his books where he just I mean it's just
absolute misinformation and and we're
gonna see here how how horribly
dishonest he is in this article too but
so he's got a whole article about how it
would be way too difficult for bears to
evolve into whales and by the way the
current model is not that bears evolved
into whales whales evolved from within
artiodactyls so our neo dactyls are
hooked animals and the closest living
relative to a whale is the hippo
but when Darwin was first speculating
about whale evolution he he he put forth
the speculation oh maybe they evolved
from something like a but like a bear
you could imagine something like a bear
spending more and more time in the water
and eventually evolving these aquatic
characteristics across multiple multiple
generations and so he's attacking that
here but in his article he has this
diagram that shows the counter current
heat exchange system that surrounds the
testicles of whales so for those that
don't know whales have their testicles
inside their body instead of having you
know a scrotum we're gonna have to talk
we're gonna have to talk about scrotums
today so hope you're out hope you're all
cool with that so obviously most animals
have most mammals hold their testicles
inside of a scrotum and the benefit
there is that we can control the
temperature of our testicles because
sperm production happens best at between
4 & 5 degrees cooler than body
temperature for most mammals that's not
true for all mammals but for most
mammals that's the case and that
actually is the case for cetaceans so
far as we can tell - they they need
their testicles to be slightly cooler
than their body temperature and because
the testicles are inside well how do you
go about doing that well the solution
that is evolved which he's pointing out
here is this counter current heat
exchange system and what this says is
you've got blood vessels that are taking
cool blood from the skin and
particularly from the tail flukes and
the the the blanking on the name of the
thing that's on a whale's back right now
the but it takes cool blood from the
skin and the outside of the body and it
pumps that around the testicles and it
pumps that near the blood vessels that
have hot blood in them and it actually
cools that blood down so that the blood
when it gets to the testicles is
actually nice and cool and it keeps them
at this temperature of about 5 degrees
cooler than the rest of the body this is
a
complicated system right these
counter-current heat exchange systems
are very complicated and his argument is
you know the internalization of the
testicle could not have preceded the
counter current heat exchange system or
the male cetacean would have been
sterile and that's a really good point
right because the main thing that if you
could say that evolution cares about
something about anything and cares and
in quotes is of course the process of
evolution is not a thinking process but
it does it does end up behaving you
could say intelligently through the
process of descent with modification
acted upon by selection you know the
thing that selection selects for the
most is fertility because what really
counts is whether or not you can pass
offspring on to the next generation so
if there is any change in morphology
that made you less likely to reproduce
well that's that changed that mutation
that caused that change that's going to
get weeded out right away so he's saying
you know internalization of the test of
the testicle could not have preceded the
counter current heat exchange system or
the male cetacean would have been
sterile yet there is no adaptive
advantage to having a counter current
heat exchange system around the testicle
unless it is inside the body so he's
like you know this is the chicken and
egg conundrum how do you get this
complicated heat system to evolve before
it's needed right seems like seems like
a difficulty seems like an issue for
evolution until you realize that guess
what all mammals already have a counter
current heat exchange system and we have
this system all throughout our bodies
when you go for a jog and you start to
blush what's happening is that you've
got this counter current heat exchange
system that's going that that's being
turned on you have by your your blood
vessels have heat sensitive muscles on
them and
when your temperature is out of whack
when your muscles are moving and heating
you up too much on the inside certain
certain vessels contract causing blood
to flow differently than normal then
when you're resting and that causes
blood to flow near the surface of your
skin it allows you to cool off allows
your the inside of your body to cool off
and in exchange temperature with with
the outside air when you get too cold
when it's too cold outside other muscles
will tense up causing blood to flow
differently
so these counter-current heat exchange
systems already exists in mammals not
only do they exist in mammals they exist
in reptiles they exist in birds they
exist in fish so this is a really really
ancient system that has been around and
evolving for millions and millions and
millions of years it it preceded the
evolution of whales dramatically and I
talked about this I actually started a
blog a few years back and back in 2016 I
actually wrote an article specifically
about this and a bunch of other claims
about whales so creationists for a long
time have been have been attacking the
evolution of whales saying that it's
impossible and there's a guy Richard
Sternberg the did a talk where he
presents 15/15 crazy changes that would
have to happen from land animal to whale
that make it impossible for whales to
have evolved and I go through that in
this in this blog article in this blog
article and I I addressed each one of
those 15 issues one of those is this
testicle issue so creationists have been
talking about whale testicles for a long
time whale balls as evidence against
evolution for quite some time now and in
this article yeah go check that out when
you when you get a chance hey I kind of
gave up on my blog I'm not really that
much of a writer it turns out I started
doing it I think there's like 10
articles on there or something or 9
something like that but yeah
I do have a blog I haven't written it
since written in it since 2016 but there
there's some cool stuff on there so go
see if you can find that when you get a
chance but this here is what what this
counter-current heat exchange system
actually looks like this is from a sheep
here pictured on the right and I got
that picture from Wikipedia we call this
I'm gonna pronounce this wrong I've
never actually heard this set out loud
so I'm probably gonna Brown this wrong
but
Radia my Rebbe Ilya that's what these
are called and it's a complex of
arteries and veins lying very close to
each other found in some vertebrates
actually turns out most vertebrates have
structures like this somewhere in their
circulatory system and it acts as a
counter-current exchanger and not only
can can this exchange heat but blood
vessels can actually exchange oxygen and
other gases this way as well what what
happens is that vessels that are flowing
and have blood flowing one way are
surrounded by a vessels that are flowing
in the opposite way and that allows
these these heat exchanges to occur and
by tightening or loosening certain
vessels you can actually control how how
how much exchange is happening so this
is a very very ancient system that it's
existed for a long time but now so okay
so so mammals already have a
counter-current heat exchange system but
do we have that in our testicles is the
the fact that whales have this exchange
system in their testicles is that a new
thing is that that have to evolve de
novo or is this a very unique special
thing to whales turns out that the
answer is no it took me a while to find
this because I'm not an expert on
testicles so I didn't just know off the
top of my head whether or not this is
the case but there is an article that I
found on a website by the
University of Missouri their Extension
Service so they for those that don't
know a lot of universities have an
extension service where they they do
kind of outreach so they'll they'll
publish a lot of their lectures and
stuff online most a lot of universities
have this now especially state-funded
universities which it's really cool you
can pretty much get an education for
free these days you won't get a
certificate well actually some some some
universities do like an extension
certificate you can go through a
training program with them and actually
get a certificate but you can get pretty
much all the information you'd ever want
for free these days which is awesome
it's new experiment and in education
that the world is is going through right
now but they have they've got a series
of articles on Bowl physiology on on
cattle for people that are raising
cattle so they can they can know what to
look out for and you know be smart about
it and they've got a whole article on
the testicles of cattle and in there
they talk about the you know most most
mammals need their testicles at about 4
to 5 degrees lower in temperature than
their body temperature in order to
maximize sperm production when when the
testicles are at body temperature they
still do produce sperm but they do it at
a slower rate so it's not total
sterilization but it's you know it's
sperm production is impeded and when
we're talking about evolution anything
that makes you slightly worse a
producing sperm that's a huge
disadvantage on an evolutionary
timescale especially with animals like
whales and with cattle that will you
know a lot of times a female will will
mate yeah maybe not so much with cattle
a lot of times with cattle there'll be a
fight and then one male will pretty much
have access to all the females in that
group but there's a lot of whale species
today that the females will melt will
mate with multiple partners and most of
the competition about who gets to become
the father happens at the level of the
sperm so producing lots of sperm is
extremely important
for species that didn't reproduce like
that you know and this does happen even
with with cattle even if one male
dominates the population and gets all
the females to himself he doesn't really
get all the females to himself there's a
lot of you know females will go mate
with other males afterwards too
and so there's a lot of competition at
the level of sperm and so high sperm
production is very important throughout
evolutionary time for males so this body
temperature needs to be regulated and
this article says that the temperature
regulation is done by coordination of
three structures a temperature sensitive
layer of muscle the Tunica darkus
located in the walls of the scrotum so
you know scrotum relaxes or tightens up
depending on the temperature this which
relaxes went hot and contracts when cold
the external again pronouncing things
i've never said before out loud the
external crema stir muscle within the
spermatic cord which controls the
proximity of the testicle to the body by
lengthening or shortening depending on
the environmental temperature and a
counter current temperature exchange
regulated by blood flow processes by a
blood flow process known as the panthan
a form plexus which is a coil of
testicular veins that provide an
effective mechanism for cooling arterial
blood entering the testicle and
transferring its heat to the venous
blood leaving the testicle so this
entire issue that Jonathan Wells a
trained biologist he wrote an entire
article about this on evolution news his
entire argument that he puts forth in an
on a website called evolution news is
completely false because apparently he
doesn't know very much about testicular
Anatomy I mean granted very few people
do spend a lot of time studying
testicular Anatomy but if you're going
to as a biologist write an article on a
website called evolution news
I do suggest looking up the topic before
you write it's extremely dishonest to
make the claim cities he's made so to
matthew h my answer to your question i
guess i guess you didn't really have a
question you just wanted me to look
things up and teach things correctly
your your issue that you have with the
evolution of wales at least the one that
you brought up to me is is a false issue
the when we read this claim again
internalization of the testicle could
not have preceded the counter current
heat exchange system or the mail
citation would have been sterile yet
there is no adaptive advantage to having
a counter current heat exchange system
around the testicles unless it is inside
the body that entire claim is false
there already is a huge advantage to
having a counter current heat exchange
system around the testicle
because controlling the temperature of
testicles is so important that even just
the the the muscles of the scrotum can't
do a good enough job of regulating that
temperature and so this system already
evolved and it already evolved within
the animals the hood animals which
whales are code animals this system
already evolved it exists in cattle and
exists in humans you have it in your own
body this is a this is a false issue
with the evolution of whales alright so
i'm going to stop sharing my screen here
i'm going to go back and look at
comments and see if there's any
questions here that i should answer
respond to here hopefully everybody's
doing this normally of course I don't
stutter as much when I'm doing videos
for stated casually and stated clearly
because I edit things so hopefully
you're okay with my stuttering here but
let's see and we got any questions here
[Music]
seems like the conversation got off
topic here in the comments someone says
man
you should have said sperm whale when
you please explain what infinite regress
is so anyone have any actual questions
that are on topic it seems like people
got into a religion debate over here
yeah people got into like a religion a
debate and John are you a geneticist no
I'm not a geneticist I am I it so I am a
I guess you could say I'm a science
journalist or science communicator I I
work with scientists
I go to their labs I work alongside
scientists to publicize their work and
simplify it for the public so stated
clearly as a project that I started in
2012 where I started doing these
animations online and the the first
animation I did is what is DNA and how
does it work and I made that on my own
just out of frustration I was frustrated
with how genetics was taught in college
we really over complicate things when we
teach genetics the way that genetics is
taught in textbooks it's not really
anyone's fault
I mean genetics is a very new field and
we've been learning it slowly and we've
been like as we learn something new we
insert that into the textbook and the
way that the way that genetics is taught
in textbooks is kind of like it's been
just evolving over time and it seems
like no-one's really just stopped and
restarted like okay how can we explain
this better now that we know all the
stuff that we know and so when you take
a genetics class it's really convoluted
you start you start off by learning
these complex things about how
nucleotides are structured and this is
stuff that doesn't really it's not that
important when you just want a really
good general overview of how genetics
works
I was refreshing with that so I'm
this video what is DNA and how does it
work five-minute video and that just
exploded in popularity teachers were
using it in colleges in high schools and
middle schools and I even got a letter
from a lady saying that she was using it
in her home school she homeschools her
kids and her daughter is 10 years old
and she watched my video now she's
teaching her friends how DNA works so
after producing that video I started
getting contacted by researchers saying
hey we're doing this and we want you to
simplify it for the public and new
animation about it and so I started
working with different universities I
work with Stewart West at Oxford he's
one of the one of the guys that I work
with and I work with the Center for
chemical evolution at Georgia Tech and
right now I'm also working with the
castle Research Center they're chemists
at UC Irvine and so I'll go and I'll
hang out with these researchers we meet
on skype I'll go to their laboratory
I've met Stu
I actually went to England and met
Stuart West got to check out some of his
research and it's it's really neat
because these people will just tutor me
it's a really neat for me way to learn
science because I have access to the top
researchers in these fields and they'll
just hang out with me they'll Skype with
me and we'll I'll go to their labs and
learn what they're doing and then I
simplify that for the public so that's
that's my my background I am NOT a
geneticist I guess you could call me a
journalist but it's this new world of
YouTube where we're not really totally
sure what to call ourselves a lot of
people will call me a science
communicator - why did the male whale
eat a boat full of sailors and or dirt
no okay that's a joke okay got it trying
to read some more questions here
why would balls evolve in the first
place okay
well that's a good
we are eukaryotes you could say that the
balls are the whole purpose of our body
like our body is an extension of our
balls you could say sorry
our bodies are an extension of either
our balls or our our ovaries so our
testicles are our ovaries we we if you
look at simpler eukaryotes like
single-celled eukaryotes
they sexual reproduction is just the
mixing of genes with a partner the
reshuffling of genes with a partner to
create offspring and there are
single-celled eukaryotes that do this as
well and multi-celled organisms the
purpose of being a multi-celled organism
I guess you say the selective advantage
leading to multi-celled organisms when
you could just have single-celled
organisms doing their thing I've got a
whole animation on that called what
caused life's major evolutionary
transitions and it goes through why
multi what types of evolutionary
pressures could have given rise to
multi-celled organisms and basically
there's there's a lot of advantage of
being a multi-celled organism you can
you can survive more varied environments
for example when you've got a nice large
body that's protecting your your sex
cells when you've got a nice large body
protecting those sex cells
you can survive crazier variations in
environment you can survive predation
from other organisms better there's lots
of advantages to being a large animal
but you really could think of our bodies
as giant machines or housing for our sex
cells like reproduction is the
foundation of biology so pretty much
everything that we do in life is to help
us either survive or reproduce and
that's that's true in every organism
plants to animals to bacteria
you know bacteria don't reproduce
sexually but they do conjugate which is
kind of similar to sexual reproduction
what they do swap genes with each other
but they don't fully shuffle their
genomes the way that we do that's that's
full-on sexual reproduction which is the
actual shuffling of genes with a partner
to produce a unique offspring that is
unique to eukaryotes which are plants
animals and like protists so there's
there's a lot of single celled
eukaryotes so anyway hopefully that
answers that question
now originally I wanted to do again I
wanted to do a third topic today hold on
let me look at more questions here so it
says oh by the way if you guys if you
guys want to be extra nice you can do a
super chat and then give me some money
and that also makes sure that I see your
comment or your question so I guess the
you know this is a Sunday morning
session so the super chat is like the
the donation plate right
I should have organ music playing in the
background and I should go on a give a
speech while there's nice organ music
playing in the background as to why you
should contribute 10% of your income to
my super chat but so someone says if we
are just an extension of our balls is
this the reason some people use their
balls to think for them I would say yes
some of us some of us have escaped the
the evil
in control of our of our behavior and
thought processes more than others die
absence sorry this is the part of the
broadcast where I mutter to myself while
reading comments
seems like people's question
have been answered so if you have a
burning question and it has not been
answered ask it right now in the chats
we asked it I guess
Oh someone gave me a super chat jay-ar
pone I don't know if I'm saying that
right um he says love your stuff job
you're an inspiration keep it up why
thank you I appreciate that
so coming about Raptors and my battery
is running low and I'm getting low on
time here so I I am
let's see any I guess someone asked
about birds having a higher than normal
temperature birds do have a higher than
normal temperature and also birds have
internal testicles I'm not sure if bird
sperm is produced at a higher
temperature than mammal sperm is I'm not
sure if they need to spend a lot of
energy cooling down their testicles or
not that's that and that's good question
but birds have internal testicles and
they run I think I want to say that
birds running the temperature about 4
degrees higher than mammals do Oh
another another contribution thank you
says love love your episode on the non
sex show
you
okay folks I'm back my computer just
died I apologize
see these are the things that I learned
in this first little experiment with
with a you know live broadcast
I should probably plug in my laptop
before I start a broadcast that would be
beneficial so I'm gonna go ahead and end
this this broadcast now hopefully I was
able to answer people's questions thank
you very much to the people who did you
know super chats I appreciate the
support thanks to everybody who's been
supporting my work over the years just
subscribing and doing it sharing my
videos and getting people excited about
this I will be doing another broadcast
next Sunday at the same time and there
I'm going to be talking about the
evolution of function from non function
I was going to do that today but as I
was creating slides last night I
realized there's so much to this that it
really deserves its own discussion so
look forward to that tell your friends
about it tweet about it my twitter
handle is at stated clearly follow me on
Twitter if you're not doing so already
and you know but a Facebook page as well
stated clearly Facebook page and yeah by
the way I'm sitting on the floor now
next next the plugin because my cords
not long enough to plug in my computer
where I was actually doing the broadcast
those are my lights back there but yes
this is a lot of fun I enjoyed it
hopefully you got something out of it
and hopefully I'll get better at doing
these as time goes on I'll stutter less
I'll ramble less and we'll get better at
this so so long for now stay curious